thank you very much the former elected
official accused of killing a local
journalist is now heading to trial this
as we are learning more now about how
police actually pieced together that
case eight news now investigator Vanessa
Murphy was in court as Robert Tellis
made an appearance
Robert Tellis appearing in court for
just a few minutes a jury trial is now
set for April in the meantime we're
learning more about the evidence police
are pointing to
custody former Clark County public
administrator Robert Tellis remains in
custody accused of killing review
journal investigative reporter Jeff
gearman video a key part of the case
Metro Police say this shows Telus
waiting for Garmin on the side of
gearman's home on September 2nd gearman
is seen walking to that area police say
only Telus is seen after and he leaves
and returns in his maroon SUV this
matches the same description as the
vehicle towed from telus's home grand
jury testimony reveals a neighbor found
gearman's body the next day according to
court transcripts detectives say they
found clothing they believe Telus wore
during the crime at his home under his
couch and in his garage
after seeing images like this the grand
jury indicted Telus for murder
April 17 2023 8 30 a.m or excuse me 10
30 a.m telus's attorney says he believes
he will be ready for trial in April he
declined to comment any further
reporting at the Regional Justice Center
in downtown Las Vegas Vanessa Murphy 8
News Now
and the review journal filed a motion
just last week to unseal additional
documents related to this case